okay next question today david can
democrats add puerto rico and washington
dc estates
without republican involvement so
there's two answers to this legally
speaking
constitutionally speaking admitting a
new state
is not a legislative matter so
the legislative filibuster that is
possible in the senate on some issues
should not actually apply and as the
week
recently published in recent years both
democrats and republicans
have in effect agreed the filibuster
shouldn't
apply to certain constitutional matters
not covered by article 1
which lays out the design of congress
and its legislative powers
the admission of new states is not part
of article 1
and it's something distinct and as a
result
in theory democrats don't need
republicans to make washington dc or
puerto rico
states now historically
this is a different matter the
idea from the framers appears to be
they clearly designated the addition of
states as not requiring
a super majority um but at the same time
it is not particularly likely that from
a practical political standpoint
democrats would go it completely alone
and from the people i've spoken to that
are
aids to elected officials there's the
belief that it is
if it is not bipartisan to some degree
that it would be unlikely to happen and
so
although from a very fundamental legal
standpoint democrats could say
we are voting to make dc a state and
it could be 50 50 in the senate and then
kamala harris could cast the
deciding vote that certainly could be
done uh i have not spoken to anyone who
thinks that it's going to actually be
done that way and that more than likely
if democrats were dead set on making dc
and or puerto rico states
even if republicans weren't uh thrilled
with it that there would be some kind of
negotiation
where republicans would get something
now what that something is i don't
actually know
one other thought on this i don't know
for sure that every democrat in the
senate
in the absence of some republicans who
want to make dc
and or puerto rico states i don't know
that every democratic senator would
actually go for it so there's actually a
question as to
whether you get to 50 50 would joe
manchin
vote to make puerto rico and dc and or
dc states
if not a single republican in the senate
plans to do it i don't know the answer
to that and there is the feeling
that there are at least one or two
democratic senators
who without some republican support for
the additional states
would not go for it the real question to
me is are we ever going to find out the
answer to this
is this actually going to be something
democrats try to do in the next two
years
as they control the white house the
house and the senate i wish i could say
yes
it's not completely clear to me